[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want and we got tammy back
hey
whoa thanks for having me we've never
filmed together before we have never
filmed together but you know what i'm
not the guest today baby i'm a regular
it's true [ __ ] this guy
it's all about me
know each other though mutual friends
probably
because we all known each other from the
back in the day entertainment circles
really
oh all of us yeah yeah yeah i met this
dude on a tour
in australia yeah the tick tick tour man
that was a great memory i mean i feel
like our mutual friend i also know from
an australia
adventure uh [ __ ] uh [ __ ] mike
song
oh oh you were doing australia myself
that was my first tour
um i thought you said canada no canada
and australia so we did a handful of
shows
uh in canada so my first ever tour that
i ever did was with uh cabo modern
cup modern and uh jay rise we did a
couple shows in canada then we went to
australia
um and uh first time going on australia
for shows and [ __ ]
australia is the bomb yo
and it's fun if you're single too and oh
yeah girls love american accents out
there
and we love australian girl accents well
that'd be mind-blowing dude
the first time i was out like my first
couple days i was out there i was
shopping
and just the first employee was like was
like um asked me if i needed to help us
i know i'm just like oh you have an
accent i was like
oh i have an accent that's what i got
and don't mind if i do
after i did a show i was like in the in
the van or whatever going back to the
like uh just wet like the girls that
were hosting us
and and i was talking about someone the
girl just like you have such a thick
american accent can you just talk i love
to hear you talk and i was like
whoa this is crazy i can talk
you say doria's you say doritos mate
[Laughter]
i do a good australian accent it's
really good
yeah man it's so fun i remember the
first time like hearing
hearing asian you know because we don't
really have like asians with accents
with like
european and australian accents out here
i remember the first time we did a show
in london
we met this girl and she had a really
like raspy asian girl she had a raspy
like british accent right of course
she's british
and then but we kept asking her to say
dirty [ __ ] so we're like yo yo yo can
you say like
can you say like um like [ __ ] my [ __ ]
she'd be like oh my god all right all
right oh my god um
[ __ ] my [ __ ] and we all go
even you saying that right now i'm like
oh my god it's not made me shiver a
little dog
it was great it was great why does this
sound so nice
it's great oh man i think it's so
different yeah because it's
me doing it but you guys know why you
said [ __ ] my closet don't don't
come on don't lie why no we're just
making her say fun stuff
i actually did not have sex with that
particular girl
it was her friend yeah but yeah
traveling's fun i know mike song yeah my
song yeah
yeah that's how we i remember when we
went to
australia at that time we were in uh
i think it was brisbane or some [ __ ]
right but brisbane we did a
after party brisbane okay we were
we were all staying in the same hotel
and then um
we i remember we were on the hotel room
we got girls to come into our room
and then
you weren't there though
[Laughter]
yeah but i was but we ended up [ __ ]
talking all night because
uh one of our other friends were
supposed to come up and it was like
three guys three girls
but it was he got lost because he was so
drunk so it was two guys three girls and
then the girl in the middle
was like i don't know no no i don't
wanna you know i don't wanna be here and
then i'm like okay you could leave but
i'm just gonna go to sleep but the other
girls want to be there
and then they're just talking talking
and we had a flight for some reason at
six in the morning i hate it
so we had like an hour from everything
and then you know we're just talking
about life and [ __ ] and i was like man
i wish i could have just came and took a
power nap but i'm going i'm gonna just
go on this plane now and i just decided
to take a shower it was like the worst
thing ever did you eat the [ __ ]
no but everybody there thought we were
all like getting laid like yeah giving
us dabs and i'm all like
yeah that's not what happened guys we
[ __ ] talked all night we talked about
life though yeah we talked about life
and [ __ ] bro water
water water water
no no no no no no no
that's always a trip we had we had um
what's what's the cat's
what i can't i can picture his face
right now but i can't hawk
cat yeah having him i could just sit
here and have him say [ __ ] all day long
i know
and the way he speaks to is like the
posh kind of english it's not even like
the dirty kind
i don't even know what the difference is
but i'm like wow it's so regal
everything says oh so
yeah everything's out he's not speaking
from like the dodgy end you know
[Laughter]
in it chatting [ __ ]
that's why they just need to have people
british accents tell people to get
vaccines
oh all right just knock off the stop
having people out there with with
with american accents that's why my siri
is uh with the british female accents
really or more nice to hear her you
could do that yeah
because she's always like wrong about
stuff anyway so might as well like sound
nice
bro i had this gps where um you could
set it to snoop dogg's voice it was like
a thing you could download
that's right yes so so he would be like
it would be like uh
you know you would be driving left yeah
yeah yeah
and then he'd be like oh you have got to
your destination my [ __ ] like
that was waves those early ways it was
and it was also like when you when you
the gps's weren't attached to your like
[ __ ] yet and you had to buy the separate
gps and like plug you know like attach
it to
like a tom tom yeah yeah it was a tom
tom why doesn't that still exist that
sounds incredible you probably could
i don't want to i want this new bug
direction thing do it probably still
have it
really he's doing like security cam
commercials now
we're hosting fights he's
he's he's not just like doing like
raptor in the fights he's also like
and seeing the fights for all i know
he's going to be in the fights next time
he was in uh wasn't he celebrity oh yeah
he always did a bunch of he did like
four or five wwe like specials but he
didn't fight did he
no he got in there and he always like
was one of those intermission things
that ended up like
doing like a clothesline or something
like that to one of the
you know snoop he's like the trump
mcmahon thing exactly yeah
you know there was a guy someone sent me
a video of this dude on stream who was
talking about how
uh in australia you guys were like the
nicest like this person was helping put
together the shows and stuff
and they were saying how like you you jk
was like the nicest people bought
everybody food at this one event
and then they were asking this guy who
was streaming who was one of the
worst people and this [ __ ] said
me and i was wow and this is why the
clip got sent why are you so [ __ ] up
was it true though no it was i'll tell
you i'll give you all the i'll give you
all the details
what'd you do timmy it was so okay so i
don't remember buying people food
never buying people [ __ ] it's like these
[ __ ]
someone sent this clip to me and this
guy was like oh i don't want to put it
out there but yeah
timothy delegato was like you know like
the worst and then so i
i [ __ ] i was like what i've always
been super nice to anybody i've like
done shows with like anybody i've me
angry with right
so i dm'd this guy i'm like bro what are
you talking about here right
and he was like oh no it was like just
one time after this show
one of the crew members was like crying
because you
and like andrew and someone else were
making fun of him i guess he deserved it
though he was like
roasting somebody and he started crying
i'm like
no that is not what happened sir let me
tell you what happened all right
because there was one australia tour
specifically
it was supposed to be called the epic is
that when you guys got us scammed when
we got super dick
yeah and we ended up calling it the epic
fail tour because everything
got [ __ ] up right like long story
short um
this dude that put the whole thing
together he was like
booking these huge venues and then
realizing that he couldn't fill the
seats because promos whack out there
literally we'd be out in like
um in like melbourne right and we'd run
into fans on the street and we'd be like
oh y'all coming to the show
tonight they'd be like what show you
know there's a show right and then so
no one knew about the show so this guy
would have to um cancel the venues at
the last minute and then so we'd be
[ __ ] like
we don't know what's going on people are
tweeting us like where's the show what's
going on we're like we don't know
like our hotel we didn't have rooms at
one point wow literally call my homegirl
in sydney be like i have no place to
stay tonight in sydney can me and rick
crash at your place
i love your accent so much
i'm sharing a guy who's trying so hard
and tim's not even appreciating how hard
he's trying
that's all i hear basically this guy
[ __ ] up
everything was [ __ ] up everyone was
pissed right and then we'd still have to
do these meet and greets and then like i
remember people tweeting like
why was like um why was everybody in
such a pissy mood you know they think
they're too cool and i was
on their facebook page like no guy you
guys don't know what's going on like you
know like shit's [ __ ] up right now
so anyways one of his dudes helpers
also was [ __ ] [ __ ] up he like left
somebody's bag
in a taxi he like left victor kim's
luggage
in a taxi and the taxi like left and
this had like a super like
uh vintage microphone that they saw he
was like tours and like a suit he had
tailored in hong kong and [ __ ]
so victor was pissed so we were like man
[ __ ] these guys right so we're
like making fun of this dude because
he's wearing the same blazer every day
for a week right
we're making fun of this dude because
we're pissed at everybody right
we're different blazers on blazers huh
when you got to clean your blazer
just you can't wear it every day depends
on who you are yeah yeah yeah
i think like three days is the maximum
okay look we're with this guy every day
for this show
and i'm talking about we're walking
around in the street and he's wearing a
v-neck
t-shirt and a blazer we're like bruh
like
but he cried because you guys just made
fun of his clothes yes
a grown man was cool he deserved it bro
and it was all like
you're trying so hard joe this is what
we just roasted each other you know but
like
like yeah we're like getting some of
this like anger
energy off and like roasted this dude a
little bit so apparently this
[ __ ] cried right i didn't know
this
today's video is brought to you by
babble
have you guys ever wanted to learn a
second third
or quad language because i always do
and you know what i said to myself
before i went to france i said i want to
paolebu francais
you know yeah i want to learn that but i
want to learn conversational
because every single time i go on and
try to learn through a book or whatever
it don't work it's words that you never
use i remember i downloaded this one app
from before
and they taught me spanish uh the word
abogado or something which is
lawyer and i'm like when am i ever going
to use that i want to learn how to order
food say hi to people how's your day i
have a conversation
i don't even use the word lawyer in
english yeah
i don't even need one i represent myself
in court so that's why i like babel
because all of the lessons are centered
around conversations and also they're
short 15 minute segments
so it's really easy you could be taking
a poopoo taking a walk
you can fit your language learning
within your whole day
and the cool thing is it was created by
language experts
there's over a hundred of them to make
sure that you
can go ahead and pronounce them right
because they speak back to you
and a lot of the times when you're
trying to learn a new language you don't
have that feedback
you know tutors are expensive this app
does it all
for you and what's cool is if you're
trying to learn a new language they got
a super awesome deal right now
if you buy three months you get the next
three months for free
so that's getting six months worth of
classes for three months
so make sure you go to babel.com that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com use the code
off the record to get this deal that's
the code off the record at babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
me me me me me me rabble you gotta make
fun of a guy harder if he does that
though
if you're over the age of 20. you're
grown man he's a grown man
maybe 17. and if you're wearing a blazer
v-neck combo
all the time you deserve to get make fun
of you and the thing about it was the
energy was the energy in our group was
we were all roasting each other too you
know what i'm saying that's
art dude that's what they think about
our friends though unfortunately
sometimes we go into places and we all
roast each other so when we roast people
right
like wait what the [ __ ] and i'm like oh
man
so i gave yeah
so this guy apparently he he he ran into
this kid that was crying i was like what
happened he told him or whatever so he's
like oh man
it's so mean he's a bully yeah so maybe
i always just buy people
food all the time everywhere we go we
always buy food though do we
i always eat it every time i'm here i
always eat the food you guys buy me
but i don't even remember a trip where
we bought food forever i love that they
try to hand you clout and you push it
away
you're like that wasn't us dude you guys
are such smart businessmen sometimes
fantastic there was that one the second
or third time went to australia i
remember you started yelling out for the
all right i got into a fight with the
[ __ ] promoter guy
this guy was deep in his computer game
he had his headphones on he didn't know
i was having a full-blown argument in
front of his face
yeah another failed australia show it
was a they rented out a huge convention
center they tried to make the whole
um failure it's like they're eating yeah
yeah they're e3 whole country in the
band
they try to make like a [ __ ] what is
it
like uh yeah yeah like a youtube yeah
yeah no the youtube one
the youtube vidcon big no yeah vidcon
vidcon yeah no more like playlist live
maybe
yeah it was it was [ __ ] you guys
failure like this guy thought that you
just bring youtubers what's his name
john
no he was like a old dude he was like an
old
australian dude he had a team whatever
blazer v-neck no but um
probably venus i didn't even know he was
running i didn't even know
his thing right but um so one of the
workers asked us to go down
into the the space like where everyone's
you know do a meet and greets in the
convention center so we go down
and then like um a tv station comes and
and they're like interviewing people and
then no one's explaining
to me what's going on or whatever so i
was like
man this is kind of crazy and chaotic
well if they don't need me i'm gonna go
back upstairs so i walk up
as i'm walking up people follow me like
a lot of the youtubers or whatever and
then we go back into the green room and
we're chilling and i'm chilling and i
feel this like
tap on my shoulder and then yeah this
and i turn around and this
old white dude's like yelling at me he
goes
you know how many how much money i spend
and this and that and whatever
and then as soon as that something just
lights in my head and i start yelling
back
and i was like what the [ __ ] you have a
shitty show you have [ __ ] volunteers
doing this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] and i was in his face
right
right dude social experiment just start
yelling at jokes
see what he does hang on [ __ ] you back
[ __ ] you blue shirt wearing
piece of [ __ ]
you know the alpha cat was right there
um
i think smosh like there was a couple of
people just watching
like the [ __ ] go down right and i'm like
who the [ __ ] are you in the first place
he goes
i run this whole thing and i'm like
you're doing a shitty [ __ ] job
and then like i guess you didn't expect
me to blow up on him like that
that's probably that's the yellow yeah
he's trying to come at me yeah he's like
i'm spending millions here and i'm like
well you should have [ __ ] spent more
[ __ ]
like
and the whole time i look over [ __ ]
and bart is like this
with his headphones on the computer like
chat bobber brigade
it was so hilarious and then and then
this guy backs down
he doesn't know what else to say he
walks away he apologizes
and then like from that point on dude
like every time he sees me he's smiling
he's open up
the door he's like kissing ass and she
love it and then i was like
man i swear to god i would have started
throwing fists at this guy because it
was such a weird thing like a kangaroo
and if you did your boy bart if he did
your boy bart
he's like
i like to do leg raises too sometimes so
when i'm feeling dirty
dude i almost forgot about that it's
been so long
but i had to get out of that room so we
went to a separate room remember that
with me and casey
we just hung out there to like chill out
for the rest of the day
but i feel like this guy um well
what i got out of it is he thought that
i was leading
this like like this protest
oh because all the youtubers strike or
some [ __ ] youtubers going on
walking away and he thought that like
dude
you can't just be here and um be a part
of this promotion
with the tv program right because they
were interviewing people
but it was so disorganized no one knew
what was we were supposed to do
so i was waiting there for like 30
minutes and i was like well i guess they
don't need me because
also there were bigger youtubers at the
time so i had i was like uh they
probably don't need me
so i walked up and he was fuming dude
and i think that the event was so
bad that he needed to take out his anger
on someone
and i was like you [ __ ] with the wrong
dude man not today
should have [ __ ] with bart
about to go down because i don't know
how to talk i only know how to fight so
i'm like
oh this isn't like it's going to fight
anytime soon
he's cracking his knuckles waiting for
the time it was funny dude
and he was like he called out a knife
you call that a usb yes
or i'd be like hey you don't want to do
this dude and he's like he's like well i
got a knife and i'm like i have a bart
oh man that was a fun time man did i
good idea like
she was trying to get boned by us three
the whole who was that girl
wait at the same time well like she was
like you guys need a ride
and then she would go with us to our
room and like hey i think we're really
tired we're jet lagged
she goes oh yeah i can just go i'll just
sit around and you guys can take a nap
and we're like we don't know who the
[ __ ] you are was he hot
no no really no it was weird you
wouldn't be bitching about it
[Laughter]
honestly i don't know how we got into
the situation but because you guys want
the sexiest she was glued to us the
whole time no you know why
it's because she wanted to hang out with
smosh
this is what we found out is that smosh
was there
and she was a big fan of them and then
just using us
we were staying at the same hotel
stepping stone yeah we were in the same
hotel right
and i thought that she was friends with
mari
so she was gonna um [ __ ] meet up with
them
and she was oh i'm going to the same
place you guys need to ride and then
that's why we're like oh i thought casey
knew her
and then you're like i thought you knew
her and i'm like wait what the [ __ ]
so none of you guys knew her no and it
goes from the event
into the car into the same elevator and
into our room and then
we're like she's in the same room in the
room chilling like why is she in our
room right now
that's confidence dude it was like it
happened in like 15 minutes right
and then i realized for the whole 20
minutes she's been talking with no
like time to breathe and then she pops
out some pills and starts [ __ ]
downing them
in our hotel room and we're just like
what the [ __ ] dude
and then we go to dinner we're like with
jays lee you know those girls that we
meet up with tony
the whole time that [ __ ] is talking and
[ __ ] and i'm like i wish there was a
girl here to like punch this girl
because i'm like
i don't even know how to deal with this
situation like i don't like it's three
dudes
we don't know how to be like hey get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] you know like
yeah that's tough that's aggressive
right like i don't know i know how to do
deal with the annoying guy but a girl it
feels so weird
in australia you just say [ __ ] because
that means it's good and bad you know
oh [ __ ] yeah no do you know what [ __ ] is
the term of us of
endearment i didn't know that he was a
good kind no whenever i was in australia
i was like you're such a [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] bro
mate mate you're such a [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] mate you're such a sucker
[ __ ] you dude bro
they love the word guns out there it's
crazy it's a term of endearment
similar thing happened to me it was this
is like 2013 right
and i'm at the youtube comedy awards
remember that [ __ ]
mcdonald was like outside like emceeing
and [ __ ] right
and nikki comes up to me
and she was not invited were you guys
together yet we were not together yet
and i was like and she was like can you
get me in and i was like i don't know if
you're going to be another one of those
smosh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
heard about them you know what i mean
because smosh is right back there and
i'm like are you here for me are you
here to [ __ ] smosh
yeah yeah so did she [ __ ] manchester yes
she went there and [ __ ] smoke
yeah she took on anthony and ian at the
same time
it's not my favorite story to the um to
the pokemon theme song
the og one yeah wow yeah not the one
from the movie that did
they did differently with orchestral
music that was a [ __ ]
crazy time this might be a dumb question
but who's smosh
smosh games or smosh it was a um i guess
a group of people's like us just a bunch
of friends doing
at one time there were like shows one
like top one or top two biggest
youtubers they were number one
what started off with just two boys oh i
i thought you're talking about smosh
game like with mario
two long-haired white boys who are just
lip-syncing and doing funny videos on
youtube probably like og like started
off like
oh six yeah yeah a lot of people want to
[ __ ] them huh
yeah well they weren't [ __ ] one of
them
i love them both they're nice fellas i
just need skits and all that you just
would only [ __ ] one of them well no i
mean
anthony for sure is the cuter one most
definitely
anthony lee baby
[Music]
huh